global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight mithu garcia
good evening we begin with a breaking
story out of surrey british columbia one
of the two men to face trial for murder
in connection to canada's largest mass
killing has been killed in what appears
to be a targeted shooting according to
his family ripo damen singh malek was
gunned down at a busy commercial complex
minutes later a burning car was found
just a few blocks away
in 2000 malik and ajayib singh bhagiri
were charged with 329 counts of first
degree murder for the deaths of those
aboard air india flight 182
the flight was brought down by a bomb on
june 23 1985 off the coast of locker b
scotland in canada's worst pre-9 11
terror attack police have always
maintained the bomb was planted by a
small group of canadian sick militants
but in 2005 citing a lack of evidence a
judge found malik and bhagri not guilty
on all counts
global's paul johnson is joining us from
surrey bc and paul you have spoken with
ripudamon singh malik's son what do we
know about the shooting this morning
well neetu from what we can gather so
far malik had just arrived at his
workplace the business that he owned in
central surrey this was approximately 9
30 this morning he was alone he was shot
before he could get inside the building
he was briefly treated for his injuries
but he died at the scene the killer or
killers apparently left the scene in a
getaway car that was found torched a few
blocks away there are few details so far
coming from police other than as you
said earlier they think this was a
targeted shooting
while this is obviously
has all of the trappings of a big
international story because of the case
against malik for the air india bombings
for which he was acquitted his family
today told us it's important that he's
also remembered for what he was to them
he was a man of faith he was a
successful immigrant to canada and he
was a father and grandfather
there is no evidence to connect him to
any theory the crown had about that
bombing
and so he he was it's not just he was
acquitted
the judge said there was no evidence
there's nothing there and so
you know
the bigger part of his life was
his community his family
and the legacy he's left with khalsa
schools coastal credit union
five kids eight grandkids
and that's his that's his legacy
malik was 75 years old he was a very
prominent man in the sikh community here
in the greater vancouver area not
because of anything having to do with
the air india bombings but as his son
was speaking about there because of his
achievements in life he founded schools
he founded what's now become a very
large and successful credit union
after the shooting this morning there
were many people turning up at the crime
scene some of them from towns throughout
the greater vancouver area a lot of them
with their own theories about the motive
here but we have to stress so far we
don't have anything that can confirm any
of this right now it's all pure
speculation and we're obviously waiting
for the rcmp to tell us what they think
happened here they've now passed this
case over to ihit that's the name of
their local major crime squad and we
hope we have answers from them soon
obviously some of those could come if
they apprehend the suspected killer or
killers we may learn more me too very
much a developing story still we
appreciate your reporting that is paul
johnson in surrey bc tonight thanks paul
shots of moderna's covit 19 vaccine will
soon be given to some of the youngest
canadians health canada has now approved
the vaccine for babies as young as six
months old and children up to the age of
five that means nearly two million more
kids will now be eligible for
vaccinations jamie morocco has more
word chloe allen can finally get her
one-year-old vaccinated doesn't come
with much fanfare two and a half years
into a pandemic in terms of having a
huge sort of relief or emotional
reaction to it
it's
you know kind of had to let go of that
more than a year since adults have had
the option health canada has finally
approved a smaller quarter dose of
modernist spike vacs with the
recommendation it may be offered to
children under six in a two shot series
given eight weeks apart
experts say although rates of infection
have risen risk of severe illness is
still rare for the littlest canadians it
really should be on a case-by-case basis
looking at the child's risk factors for
a severe disease does the child have an
underlying medical condition that can
put them at risk for more severe covet
19 and other parental and family
concerns modernist says the results
showed a 51 efficacy rate at preventing
symptoms in children 6 months to 2 years
old and 37 effective against symptoms in
kids 2-5 the efficacy is good it
protects against
infections that would lead to
hospitalizations or death trials didn't
include omicron's latest sub-variant
ba-5
that's it in the u.s modernist vaccine
has already rolled out and in some
states hesitancy has been high real
world data is limited but modernist
clinical trial reported no deaths cases
of severe covet 19 or miss c
multi-system inflammatory syndrome
sabinavorja miller's son was one of 500
canadian kids who participated he
received two doses of the drug i think
for the most part he was okay he was
tired after the vaccine a common symptom
post shot in addition to soreness and
irritability as well as temporary loss
of appetite short-term pain this family
says for a healthy gain it hurts kind of
but did you regret getting it or are you
happy to have gotten it i i'm happy
because i'm protecting
my family from getting sick and now
there'll be more protection available
than at any point in the pandemic before
jamie morocco global news toronto
random coven 19 testing for air
travelers is making a comeback in this
country starting tuesday those arriving
at the airports in montreal vancouver
calgary and toronto may once again be
selected to be tested but there will be
one key difference from the previous
program mike armstrong has the details
mike
well neither traveling through canadian
airports like here in montreal is tough
enough right now not everyone's keen to
see covid testing return
not at the moment no
it just confuses things and holds things
up
it wasn't hard to find people against
the idea but there are those who aren't
disappointed i think it's good because
it is back
when covent testing returns next week
for people traveling by air it won't be
at the airport travelers coming back on
international flights will be able to go
to a testing facility a pharmacy or even
do it virtually with a monitored self
swap now for people who qualify as fully
vaccinated only some will have to be
tested they'll be picked at random and
have until the end of the next calendar
day people who aren't vaccinated will
have to be tested in fact twice they
have to do 14 days of quarantine and
tests on day one and day eight
moving the testing out of airports the
federal transport minister says is to
try to make things run more smoothly he
says the government's trying to make
airports work better right now not worse
we recognize that testing at airports
what was adding a layer of congestion
now experts we spoke to question how
effective this program will be it's not
going to prevent covid from entering the
country the government says that's not
the point that is to be able to track
how much covet is coming in and monitor
for new variants nothing wrong with
testing and getting genome sequencing on
people returning to find out you know is
a new variant or sub-variant starting to
come into canada more often it's
probably not going to control the
numbers but knowing that information can
be potentially useful to public health
as for how people will be selected for
testing that'll be done through the
arrivedcan app people will make their
customs declaration and then be notified
by email they've been chosen as for how
many people will be tested the
government says it's about five percent
of people returning to canada nethu
mike armstrong reporting tonight thanks
mike
hockey canada says it's reopening an
investigation into an alleged sexual
assault involving members of the 2018
world junior team recently the national
federation was dropped by corporate
sponsors and had its federal funding
frozen after it quietly settled a
lawsuit with a woman who said she was
assaulted by eight players while her
allegations were never tested in court
the settlement triggered outrage from
fans and politicians as abigail beeman
reports now hockey canada is taking
steps that could put it on the right
path
we know we have not done enough to
address the actions of some members of
the 2018 national junior team or to end
the culture of toxic behavior within our
game reads hockey canada's open letter
for that we unreservedly apologize
hockey canada promises to reopen the
third party investigation into what
happened this time players who don't
participate will be banned from national
programs and events it will also require
mandatory sexual violence and consent
training and promises a new independent
and confidential complaint process it's
like well you finally got hit in your
wallets
and and now you're you're
saying you're going to do something for
many the letter is lacking it only came
out after big sponsors such as tim
hortons and canadian tire distanced
themselves we saw sponsors walking away
from the world juniors which is probably
one of the most lucrative
tournaments that they run in in terms of
funding so i really think it had a huge
role perhaps they're motivated by the
wrong things but i think it's the right
thing to do i think that the engagements
that were taken by the organization are
a good step in the right direction the
sport minister says she wants hockey
canada to sign up with the new sport
integrity commissioner and more training
to change the culture something many say
isn't easy to have this training only
available to higher level players isn't
going to shift a culture it really
becomes you know like a band-aid or
we'll run our players through this
training so now we're good where they're
being praised at the national and
international level for violence things
get mixed up and the culture becomes
very complicated and very intertwined
with that violence hockey canada did not
respond to a request from global news it
also has not committed to making the
results of the investigation public or
turn them over to the government abigail
beeman global news ottawa
russia is expanding the territory its
forces are targeting not only fixing its
sights on government and military
facilities but civilian infrastructure
after russian rockets hit an office
building medical center and nearby
apartments 200 kilometers southwest of
kiev veneza a city in the middle of
ukraine is nowhere near the front lines
of the war in ukraine's dawn bass but
was pummeled by cruise missiles fired
from a submarine in the black sea in the
middle of the morning killing at least
22 people
as crystal gamansing reports the attack
is one of the deadliest single strikes
on a civilian target since russia's
invasion of ukraine
a devastating and deadly strike on a
city up until now unscathed by the war
ukrainian officials say russia fired on
civilians from a submarine in the black
sea veneza is where the ukrainian air
force is headquartered
this man explains the first floor of the
most heavily damaged building was a
medical diagnostic center which provided
people with therapy and access to
surgery
the attack set off a frenzied search for
survivors ukraine's national police
service says three children are among
those killed
this video is circulating widely on
social media the little girl is believed
to be one of the young victims
two videos posted put the child in the
area at the time of the strike she
attended a kids club hosted by a speech
pathologist
during yet another presentation to his
international political counterparts
vladimir zelinski said the attack was an
act of russian terror in the east more
bloodshed the head of the russian-backed
donetsk people's republic accuses
ukraine of shelling a bus station in the
city of donetsk using a howitzer
the powerful long-range weapon systems
were provided to ukraine but officials
deny shelling the city
donetsk has been held by pro-russian
forces since 2014.
ukrainians say russians
fired on their own location outside of
the country some diplomatic progress
ukraine and russia have agreed to form a
coordination center a step that could
see ships safely transport ukrainian
grain out of odessa a russian blockade
has stranded dozens of ships in the
black sea
a full deal could be signed next week
helping to ease the world food shortage
crystal gamansen global news
london
american basketball star brittany griner
was back inside a russian courtroom
today after pleading guilty to drug
possession charges last week the case
against the american is widely believed
to be politically motivated while
negotiations between the white house and
the kremlin for a potential prisoner
swap can't happen until the case is over
griner was arrested in february one week
before the russian russians launched the
invasion of ukraine she had been
returning to the country to play
basketball when moscow police say they
found vape canisters containing cannabis
oil in her luggage if griner is found
guilty she could face up to 10 years in
prison
the symbolism was impossible to miss as
troops representing the nato nations of
central and eastern europe led the
annual bastille day parade in paris
military delegations from the nato
countries which border russia marched
ahead of french troops in a show of
unity the parade also featured examples
of some of the military hardware now
being provided to ukraine
italy's in crisis coming up the view
from rome as the prime minister's
resignation leads to government chaos
italian prime minister mario draghi
resigned his position today well at
least he tried to draghi offered to step
down after an ally refused to support a
key government bill but italy's
president rejected it telling draghi to
try and find a majority willing to
support him mike trolley reports
in the midst of a heat wave debilitating
drought and soaring energy prices
italians scoffed at the possibility its
government could collapse sending the
country further into turmoil
this man called the possibility madness
at a time when the country is recovering
while their worst fears became reality
as italy's coalition government couldn't
agree on a path forward to economic
recovery which led to prime minister
mario draghi announcing his resignation
which italy's head of state president
sergio matarella rejected demanding
draghi address parliament in hopes of
finding a solution and avoiding a
political cliff
now if italy is forced into
an election one of the front-runner
parties is the far-right brothers of
italy and so this is a a neo-fascist
party and so this could be potentially
quite destabilizing for italian politics
so it is it is
it's terrible timing
draghi was seen as a unifying force in
italian politics but had recently
clashed on social issues with giuseppe
conte the leader of the left-leaning
political party five star but political
tensions are particularly high regarding
ukraine which italy has supported
despite historically close relations
with russia you can't help but wonder
whether
you know those policy differences are
really being overplayed to compensate
for the the internal party split that
that really occurred over this foreign
policy difference over ukraine if draghi
can't be convinced to form a new
government italy's financial crisis
could spiral out of control if the eu
demands political stability before
signing over billions of euros from its
coveted recovery fund
mike drolite global news
hours after fleeing to singapore in the
face of mass protests sri lankan
president gotabaya rajapaksa has now
stepped down
the announcement was met with jubilation
in colombo where protesters had gathered
in defiance of a government-ordered
curfew months of protests over the
country's runaway inflation and the
resulting economic meltdown escalated
over the weekend with demonstrators
storming government buildings and the
presidential palace the country's prime
minister a close ally of rajapaksa has
now been named acting president
next the search for the missing after
intense rains ravage parts of virginia
more than 40 people who were missing are
all now accounted for after a string of
severe storms hit parts of virginia as
much as 15 centimeters of rain came down
in just a few hours overnight causing
flash floods and landslides at least 100
homes have been badly damaged or
destroyed but no one was seriously hurt
wildfires are tearing through parts of
spain and portugal as much of western
europe is in the grips of a
record-setting heat wave more than
6-thousand people have been evacuated
from their homes as temperatures in the
low to mid 40s have been recorded across
the iberian peninsula thursday is
expected to bring even hotter
temperatures but there's no relief in
the forecast until at least early next
week a previously unknown self-portrait
by vincent van gogh has been discovered
hidden underneath one of the painter's
other works the discovery was made
during an x-ray examination of van
gogh's 1885 head of a peasant woman the
image was hidden behind cardboard and
layers of glue van gogh is known to have
often reused his canvases and experts
are now trying to figure out how to
uncover the self-portrait without
damaging the other work
next not playing ball why a bunch of
kansas city baseball players will sit
out the series against the blue jays
tonight baseball fans are calling foul
on a group of kansas city royals players
who aren't playing ball with canada's
coveted rules ten royals players will
miss tonight's game in toronto against
the blue jays and the rest of the series
because as shalima maharaja explains
they're not willing to get vaccinated
the choice was in their hands and
ultimately they chose not to get the
shot 10 players on the kansas city
royals roster will sit out the series
against the blue jays unvaccinated and
ineligible to enter canada forfeiting
four days of pay
yes they're young and they're healthy
and they're professional athletes so
chances are they're not going to have a
really terrible outcome if they get
covid but at the same time you know we
had eduardo rodriguez who was the
opening day starter or supposed to be
the opening day starter for the red sox
in 2020 missed the whole season because
he had complications from kovitt some of
the club's top players among them
outfielder andrew benatendi will
reportedly lose more than
186 thousand dollars u.s infielder
whitmer field over 150 000 and starting
pitcher brad keller is set to take a hit
north of one hundred and six thousand
dollars you know it's not really just a
good look you know mlb wants a good
product on the field and
you know a lot of
star players aren't playing but it's a
decision they made this comes on the
heels of other high-profile athletes
refusing to get vaccinated i'm not going
to let canada tell me what i do and
don't put in my body for a little bit of
money kyrie irving's choice cost him
millions and kept him sidelined
throughout much of the nba season
in january novak djokovic made headlines
when he was deported from australia over
his vaccination status no australian
open then and he may miss next month's
u.s open too we hear about canada's
border regulations and how tough canada
is it's exactly the same in the united
states so if the blue jays had
unvaccinated players which they don't
the full roster is fully vaccinated but
if they had unvaccinated players they
would have to play only road games it's
true but the jays players and coaches
have avoided covet outbreaks there's no
easy series in the big leagues is i
guess the best message
any given night any given guy can do any
given thing
the royals missing almost half their
squad because they wouldn't give
themselves a shot shaleema maharaj
global news toronto
and that is global national for this
thursday night i'm nitu garcia tonight's
your canada is the sunrise over the pier
in thornbury ontario we love to see your
canada please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
[Music]
you